[Music]
[Music]
Daisy now that you have seen the
completed version of the rise of
Skywalker tell me the first reaction you
had when the credits hit my head was
literally spinning
I saw JJ come here and be like you okay
and I was like yeah I think I'm okay
and it was yeah it's it's overwhelming
mm-hmm and it was cool it's cool it's
even though it's it's strange watching
oneself and there's a lot of that that
is to digest but in general I really
think the film is great it's so quick
and punchy you're so with all the
characters and I was asking my sister
who worship with me you do understand
why people are doing the things you they
are it definitely requires a second
watch because so much goes on but it's
so great and such and as Richard said
it's such a beautiful ending yeah I
think people will be happy you know as
an actor what is the most satisfying or
fulfilling part about playing a
character across three films and doesn't
maybe have something to do with
continually learning something new about
her the thing is I'm not one of those
people that comes in is like I'm in
character I say the words and do the
thing and then I guess it becomes the
character so I don't think of it so much
like that but I think looking back it's
gratifying the stuff I never imagined I
would do it the first time around I'm
doing this time around and I've had the
space to do that so I've got to be Rea
starting out which she was and I was and
now we're here so I think it's that it's
being able to continue to try stuff and
develop and yeah how has being in these
films giving you a new appreciation for
fandom in general like how much do you
add or like the reloj fandom aspect of
these films and just do you have a new
appreciation for for fans I think I have
a new appreciation for people that
really stick with something my trainer
is a Tottenham Hotspurs fan Tottenham
Hotspurs last year weren't winning
anything but he's a
of them it doesn't matter if they win
its he loves the team and I think with
Star Wars even though everybody has an
opinion there's always a conversation
people aren't going to be happy
people have stuck with this for over 40
years and there is really something to
be said for the endurance of that to
continue to love something and even if
you don't agree to continue to be part
of a conversation about it for sure I
think it's amazing and that people are
so creative and it means so much it's
it's it's crazy
because I don't have that about anything
I'm like wow do I love anything enough
to travel somewhere for it but it's I
would love to know how that feels and I
think it's amazing that people love it
this much okay could I just ask you a
quick looking back at the saga favorite
moment from the nine films that you have
oh I don't know it's it's tough I mean
the last few days has been really nice
because you think now is more of a
chance to reflect on everything and you
look down a row of people and you're
like I genuinely liked and loved all of
you probably that
and no one does
[Music]
I do
[Music]
so playing kylo Ren over the course of
three films as an actor what is the most
sort of satisfying aspect of playing a
character over the course of a trilogy
does it have something to do with the
fact that you're continually learning
something new about him that's a good
question yeah from the first meeting
that I had with JJ he gave me an overall
arc of what what he imagined the
character would would do so where he
would start the third movie no one knew
how would it end and even when we
started that we no one knew how it ended
so to finally build towards something
for six years that you have in the back
of your mind was you know an exercise in
patience you know get you that you it
affected everything that we did in the
force awakens everything that we did and
in the second one and obviously what how
we started the third one so hopefully
that hopefully it worked you know we're
looking back at the saga nine films this
is the finale of those nine films do you
have a particular favorite moment from
the entire saga and maybe it's a moment
that helped even inform your performance
of kylo Ren no I mean there's so many
things that you're surrounded by it so
many set pieces and actors who are
giving you so much information that you
know in a way it's it's hard to kind of
retreat into yourself because there's so
many answers in front of you even in the
costume the costume from the very
beginning was something that was
ill-fitting and tight you know that
evolved over three movies so like what
does that say about the character he's
wearing a mask you know what does that
say about what he's hiding who he's
presenting to the world versus who he is
you know he has a lightsaber that
doesn't work or gets gives you the
impression that it could self-destruct
at any minute a minute there's so much
information and that that it was helpful
as far as moments on set there's it you
know too many to count that it's you
know mark being on set for the first
time having a scene with him and really
like you know having a moment of alright
Star Wars I forgot that or you know
force awakens peeking in when Harrison
and and Carrie had a scene
you know playing ping pong in between
takes and you have like you know yonas
and Oscar and I you know all playing
ping pong with you know with people and
the crew it was just it's a bunch of
things like that that all that I'll
think about not specifically one
tentpole moment you know the fandom of
Star Wars is its own crazy extra level
of hype when it comes to kylo Ren
there's like a sub section where they
romanticize reloj the the the
relationship between rey and kylo Ren
are you aware of that stuff does it make
you happy do you have a new appreciation
of fandom sort of being install wars and
seeing the imaginations and nooks and
crannies that that fans sort of inhabit
and create their own sort of fanfiction
I guess I mean I don't turn a little
internalize it because I don't know that
it has much to do with me if anything I
think it has to do with the strength of
the movie that one of and what makes
these movies Universal and have not only
but stretch kind of across time is that
yes there's a huge obviously you know
visual element that's going on that's
very satisfying there's you know it's
it's beautiful to look at but no one
will care if you don't care about what
these human themes that are what
propelled the movie forward this thing
of like Luke being a kid from a small
town who feels like he's destined for
something greater about friendship and
discovering your place you know among
your friends your family that you've
acquired and family that you're tied to
how do you things about them that you
identify with are things that you're
trying to run away from all these you
themes are the things that make the
spectacle of it more exciting and
interesting
it's an instinctive feeling
or surprise you together first question
now that you've seen the completed
version of the rise of Skywalker what
was your first reaction when the credits
hit I'm still numb so figure it out it's
a whole process for us isn't like just
watching a film and asking you know
where do you like it you know it's just
the whole mental mental process it's
significant it is its significance is
much more than just a film for us it's
like a time in our lives a time spent
with each other so you know I need to
watch it again because I'm still still
processing for sure I am what is
something new that you learned about
Finn on this third time around playing
him learned by him I think because
because I was actually impart in those
new ideas into Finn I think you know
that was exciting to have a fresh new
take especially when it comes to his
energy a lot more growth as a person
between 7 and 9 older much more Stern
you know gets into a few little
arguments you know it's a bit much more
of a you know a grounded dude that just
wants to get it done I think that that
was something I was quiet and excited by
you know we're looking back at the whole
saga with this being the finale do you
have a favorite moment favorite scene
from the nine films and maybe it's
something that helped inform your
performance of it yeah
no but I I dude there's a moment that
always makes me laugh when obi-wan is
fighting Anakin and obi-wan tells Anakin
the reason why is one basically is
essentially because he's got the higher
ground you know that moment I'm always
like why are you telling him that for
but keep that to yourself
roar and just get the work in yet yeah
that's a funny moment I always like I
love that'sthat's that duel that do is
sick
I mean sometimes they're just doing it
they're just swinging for no reason as
they you can just tell they're just
through his skills but that's not cool
you know fandom for this film has been
crazy and it's those all kinds of
subsections you got your Finn Poe your
reloj do you have a new appreciation of
fans and
fandom having been a part of this series
and and if so what's your favorite sort
of explore new appreciation you know
part of the fandom before before signing
on to the films which the film's watch
in you know the the anime it shows and
play in a video game so I understand
that I just didn't know they shipped
like I didn't know these guys were like
against each other I thought it was like
a whole come loving community of
different types of ships know the tripod
array lows against you know anyone
else's it's a whole war going on which
I'm not involved in love for you or so
it's been it's been nice to express
thats been new sides to the fandom where
I've been like oh it's like an actual
track listen tribal stuff going on
it's been cool you know and now that
will you're finishing this up you know
what's your biggest takeaway in terms of
why this series has endured for 40 plus
years what do people love it so much I
mean for me that's kind of what Richard
said like I I see the influences
especially that III was just a bit a big
advocate of of what the inspiration
which I have behind george lucas's take
on this and you know you've got the
bible in greek mythology
you know that just that the essence of a
view on life and and good and evil that
stuff really really speaks to me and
obviously it speaks to a whole bunch of
people i also think it's fun you can
interact with it in several different
ways if you're not into the film's you
can read the portion it's a books you
prevail video games so many different
ways to do it and so I think it's just
it just will survive generations
[Music]
all right so when you first took on the
role of Lando way back in the Empire
Strikes Back do you remember what you
were most interested in learning about
the character before you played him well
you know what I got when I found out I
was going to wear a cape and also the
name Calrissian Raquel risen I am is
Armenian I thought that was those two
elements or aspects or elements when I
thought were two things that I could
really do some interesting stuff with
putting on that cape sort of helped you
feel a little bit more
well the cape and then but the name also
sort of took it was it allowed me to
become much more than what one would
imagine bigger-than-life character for
sure as a follow up to that what's
something new that you learned about
Lando embodying the character all of
these years later well the way he's
being presented now I think if there's a
kind of depth you didn't see with Lando
in the Empire or The Return of the Jedi
the Empire was an introduction Return of
the Jedi think that they Alan whiskey
you almost got the feeling that they
didn't quite know what direction to take
Lando you feel like his story concludes
in this film I hesitate to say concludes
let me put it that way you know when you
got behind the wheel of Millennium
Falcon again all these years later what
was did a memory flash before you what
was the first thing that you thought
about well I mean I thought about you
know the first time I I sat in the
Millennium Falcon in Return of the Jedi
it was free and I was curious to see if
what it would be like and it was pretty
much the same except you had a different
film director working with JJ is
a lot of fun and very exciting he's a
he's a very imaginative kind of
individual you know as a legacy member
of Star Wars why do you think all of
these years later 40-plus years later
Star Wars is so important to people in
their lives from all over the globe well
for certainly it's a great adventure
it's an epic adventure but I think also
it addresses the whole question of the
light in the dark you know good and evil
outside of yourself and also there's the
this struggle with with the dark side of
yourself as opposed to the light side of
yourself within yourself so I think that
that'd be I think that's pretty much a
universal theme and most of our lives
and I think even when we don't think
about it when we're not aware of it but
we're but it's always there we're always
dealing with things that are good and
evil outside and we're always dealing
with that with the universe within
ourselves
and now
you're coming together
all right so now that you have seen the
completed film the rise of Skywalker
tell me your first reactions when the
credits hit
I just astounded at JJ's talent that's
kind of that's the first thing that I
felt the fact that he stuck the landing
and in such a spectacular way that was
my first feeling just the credits well I
loved the ending of it and uh I was just
overwhelmed and I just went and gave JD
the biggest hug because I I know he felt
so much pressure to he was felt so
respectful of the people who loved this
and he's a fan of it but it's just so
good in it it totally delivers Carrie
has a newcomer to the series what was
the moment where you paused and you
looked around you and you said holy crap
him in a Star Wars movie there was a
moment when I saw a large number of
stormtroopers walking and I was like oh
my god I'm in Star Wars yes you know
Oscar for you how satisfying it is is it
for an actor to play a character across
three films and does it have something
to do with continually learning
something new about a character yeah
I've never had that experience where you
know you do something and then you wait
to find out what's gonna happen but that
character later and not really knowing
and not knowing if what you're doing now
is effect you know it's like if I'm bad
in will they not write me into the next
you know like there's a lot of you know
a lot of in my already neurotic mind you
know stuff to really get me going so
that was a challenge but like you said I
think there was something really fun
about each film allowing to find a
different facet of how historian folds
and and the arc of someone that starts
off as a dedicated soldier becoming a
leader you know we're looking back at
the saga nine films this is the finale
do either of you have a favorite Star
Wars moment from the films and maybe
it's a moment that helped inform your
performances in some way
for me looks just the thing that I
always think about are those early like
cantina scenes with the crazy music and
the åland and there was a moment and
like where I felt that a little bit that
one and I you know that's one of the
coolest things about Star Wars they
don't make movies like this anymore it
feels like one of those old John Huston
movies where you move to this far-off
place for two years and they spent all
this time doing costume fittings and
designing things and the artistry that's
what Star Wars still is and they don't
make those movies anymore and like those
cantina scenes just the world that
you're transported into I think that's
why like they've had a particular way of
igniting people's imaginations and
making you feel like there is so much on
the outer edges of the frame that's
happening you know there's like all
these worlds that are hinted and I think
that's also why it made me that like the
people want the information because
they're they've imagined so many
possibilities yeah it's just very unique
you know I can't think of any other
thing that causes like that one little
item make someone think of like what
will that come from and yeah those like
who are the parents like who cares who
the parents of characters are usually
wants to know who's you know it's kind
of an amman and how it all fits into the
puzzle yes giant myth yeah what are you
doing there are three Pele taking one
last look sir
but my friends as you're getting ready
to work on the rise of Skywalker you sat
down with George Lucas again what was
the most important thing that you wanted
to learn from him this time around as
you got ready to finish the story that
he started we just want to sit down and
hear whatever he had to say and he
talked quite a bit about the force and
what it meant to him and you know all
sorts of things that that were less
story specific and more about to sort of
approach and and the spirit with which
he felt we should approach our job and
we tried to incorporate as much of that
as we could though he didn't work on the
story per se with us it's not like that
was was what he was doing but he was you
know someone we you know we wanted to
hear from as much as he would be willing
to talk to us and he was incredibly
generous you know I'm kind of obsessed
with the naming of Star Wars characters
I feel like once a Star Wars character
his name that name becomes iconic and do
you have a process for naming characters
like take Zuri bliss for example where
do these names come from it's a strange
thing it really is like with everything
with every design with every you know
sequence with every costume anything
it's it's it's a feeling of what you
know your gut says like what what is the
right thing a lot of these names are
things that just you know literally
comes to they can they come to us and
we'll live with it for a while and they
defend themselves like if it's not quite
the right name you feel it after a few
hours a few days a few weeks you'd start
to get when something feels like it's
working it just sticks and some
characters get named instantly and
that's their name forever
others go through dozens of names until
finally you choose one you know we're
looking back at the saga the nine films
do you have a favorite moment favorite
scene from the saga and maybe it's a
scene that you went back to as you were
getting ready to work on these films
that helped well I mean I went back to
watch all the movies again early on
anyway but the the one scene I always go
back to just because there's something I
mean there's so many scenes but from the
original new hope was just the scene
where you meet Han there's just
about meeting Han Solo that is just so
instantly timeless instantly classic you
know one of the obvious obviously one of
the greatest characters one of the great
scenes so it's just um
for some reason I always go to that then
I as I'm saying it I start to think of
the dozens of other scenes I'm like yeah
but what about you know so it's hard to
choose more you know as a Star Wars
superfan yourself what do you hope to
see from the next iterations of big
screen Star Wars films that that come
after this one as a fan you know as a
fan I just want to be surprised I want
to be taking places that I would love to
think continues that sense of
hopefulness
and-and-and possibility I mean that
that's the thing that Star Wars does I
think better than anything which is make
you feel like anything is possible and
you know you're your new best friend is
someone you're gonna meet in the most
you know unlikely place I just think
there's something you know the adventure
you're going to go on the the challenges
that will be ahead of you that we're all
capable of incredible things that the
family that we make is the family that
it really matters I just there's so many
aspects of Star Wars that are profound
to me and in whatever form it takes
those are the kind of elements that I
think you know are about the big heart
at the core of Star Wars which I'd love
to see continued
[Music]
so my first question for you now that
you've seen the completed version of the
rise of Skywalker what was your first
reaction when it ended whoa Wow nearly
whoa Wow
because JJ's pulled off a master stroke
absolutely yeah really just a release of
energy and emotion that the film created
it's it's unbelievable you know we are
looking back at this the entire saga all
nine films here and Anthony I'm
especially interested to hear your
answer to this because you have been a
part of all of those films favorite
moments or favorite moment from the saga
favorite moment of the saga was were so
many actually but coming back for the
start of episode 9 with the old team and
also carry it in in a certain way being
part of it all and with some new
characters coming in and all the time
JJ's wonderful enthusiasm I'm gonna keep
my ass for a very brief favorite moment
Luke drinking blue milk that's my
favorite that's just like shows you Star
Wars the way mixed realism and and then
fantasy and and that it's just so Star
Wars to me that moment just so out of
this world but still grounded in and in
our world you know June is one thing
that we get a lot of questions about
Chewbacca is Chewbacca have lines and do
you yell them through the costume at all
Chewbacca has sometimes his lines and
sometimes I asked for the intent and
what would the line be so I can you know
wookie speak that line so I go so I'm
inside the mask and I'm yeah that's the
legibility of my words is they don't
hear me work very well so that it
certainly helps you making noise
it helps and it's it's a yeah it's it's
it's a much better reaction III able to
influence the timing of the dialogue
with my grunts and moans Threepio
has
a little bit more a lot more to do in
the rise of Skywalker and I'm just
curious after nine films what's
something that new that you learned
about playing the character this time
around well he is but a pretty static
character he is a machine but it very
much depends who he's put against who
he's who he's come who are his
companions and very much what the script
gives him to do and in this one he is
given to do something that is quite a
challenge and that's just so refreshing
otherwise you know it is just standing
there doing the same thing all the time
so suddenly I had a real gift from JJ
you know here we are 40 plus years later
what do you think it is about Star Wars
that is it endures and it is still so
beloved around the world what would you
say that that is the second most the
question I get asked is it hot in the
costume and why it to Star Wars India
what do you think
I think JJ said it best and that's it's
the end-all answer to this question it's
it's the hope that the sometimes naive
but always warranted hope that that Star
Wars represents and George started the
first one we absolutely hope
[Music]
the force will be with you boys so Naomi
let me start with you as a newcomer to
the Star Wars at what point what was the
moment where you stopped and paused and
looked around and said holy crap I'm in
a Star Wars movie oh there's so many of
them I think probably that one of the
first moments I did that was when we
were putting my costume together and
like I I you know it's a giant mirror
obviously and there was loads of people
like attaching different things and it
was really at a point where we had found
the backstory for the costume and the
reasons why things were where they were
and I like looked in the mirror and I
was just like because it didn't it
didn't look like me usually the
characters I play are contemporary and
usually in the present day so this was
the first time that I felt like out of
this world and it really it messes with
you a bit but in like the best way Kelly
what was the most fulfilling part about
completing roses journey in this film I
think just working with the amazing
people that I got to work with I feel
really really fortunate to be able to
have worked with such amazing actors and
meeting new people okay I'm really
excited
is there something cool that you got to
do as ROS in this film that you didn't
get to do in the previous film that you
kind of geeked out on a bit sure
yeah I think working with again working
with the different people that I didn't
get to work with last one last time um
that would be the best thing you know
we're looking back this completes a saga
of nine films when you look back at the
nine films do you have a favorite Star
Wars moment I mean there are so many
iconic ones I'm so I stole this was the
my first memory of Star Wars is to like
yeah
yeah like that's like to me that's like
just inside that you know you'd roleplay
that with with your other friends in the
in the playground so that's the first
thing that comes to my mind yeah I think
seeing Chewie and Han Solo and the
Falcon like just like that was really
cool and it's really cool yeah did you
you've seen the completed film at this
point you saw yesterday yeah what was
can you give me your first reaction when
when the film ended I was like and I
like turned and like my heart was being
so fast and it was it was such a
celebration and I think everyone felt
relieved you know it's been months and
months of work yeah and also Arzak I
think I need to go to sleep because it's
so it's such an assault on the senses
from you know the different characters
and the amazing visuals that I was like
there's so much information that I
needed to like take a second alone and
just be like wow okay yeah it's a lot
yeah yeah I agree I think it's really
hard to process when you're sitting
there with everyone who helped make it
you're like ah but it was really yeah
just like the visuals of it and just the
magnitude yeah okay it's just insane
I've never seen any anything like it and
and also just being there with you guys
and it felt such a surreal moment to go
to bad robot and cinema quick casual
just not you know some so what there's
like sour patch sour patch kids teased
or whatever yeah like you know just
casually watching the film that we made
yes crazy
you